uh
[Music]
let's get started so welcome back for
the afternoon session of the first day
of the meet the fellows event for fall
2022. so we have two sessions uh in the
afternoon and uh in the first session we
have four talks and the first talk would
be given by tara who has changed the
title uh but i you know he says
underlying math is the same on spectral
algorithms and power of two uh spectral
algorithms in fact so it's latent
recovery in complex networks with
missing data
okay thanks uh hello i'm show week uh
i am now research fellow here before
coming here i was a postdoc from the
postdoc at
mit math department and microsoft
research new england so i would like to
tell you some recent results
of latent recovery problems in complex
networks especially when you have
missing data on the network okay
so
first
let's see an example which is classical
and it relates out of the clustering
problems and latent structure recovery
problems on network so this is uh the
belgium telephone network uh where edges
represent people calling each other
and nodes are
nodes are people
and
you can see that there are clearly two
separated clusters in the network
and
it turns out that these two separate
clusters represent the two largest
linguistic groups in belgium the
dutch-speaking population and the
french-speaking population
okay so
the
thing to note here is that if we can do
clustering on a network then we can
figure out
hidden traits of the nodes that are
present in the network like which
language that they speak right
so
in general uh
communities are densely connected parts
of the network and usually we are given
an unlabeled observation like this we
don't know anything which are
communities and from that we have to
construct back the communities
and
so we want to divide the graph based on
an unlabeled observation and it's an
unsupervised learning task and has
many applications in specially data
mining for example if you look at
building better recommendation systems
uh our webpage sorting algorithm as well
as
in order to understand how a different
anatomical segregation of human brain
works and also uh
how to give you friend suggestions in
social networks like facebook community
direction underlies
all these problems
and for so many applications there has
been a huge development there has been
many fundamental results in this
direction
and it is a now well developed field but
most of this later
you can find is in the context where you
have full information about the network
if it's available okay
however in practice that is often not
the case we often have sensor data in
modern context and that can arise due to
reasons like privacy noise and in many
cases we don't see the network we only
see the network by some sampling
procedure so there is always a partial
observation of the net network and we
have sensor data
and there are two
questions that we can ask here the first
is when is recovering uh cluster
recovery of clusters possible or
impossible right depending on
whether you care about deleting the
information
of communities you would probably care
about the impossibility part but if you
care about recovering communities
you would care about the possibility
part so this question the answer to this
question is kind of a two-edged so
from a more computational point uh
yeah the important question is are there
scalable algorithms for community
detection and we want to find algorithms
that are optimal in the sense that
whenever it is information theoretically
possible to do the recovery the
algorithm should be able to find it
okay
so this was high level uh so now just to
show you some concrete results let's uh
consider a generative model which is
simple but we will see that already in
this simple model if we have sensory we
will get some different behavior
so each vertices in this model are
assigned to one or other community with
some probability though and edge
probabilities in community one or two
they arrive with probability p1 and p2
and between communities they arise with
probability q
and additionally we have the censoring
so each edge is revealed to us with some
probability log n over n so most of the
data is missing only log n over n
many data is revealed to us and this t
parameter is sort of controlling how
much information has been given to us
and we observe this unlabeled graph and
between each pair of vertices we either
know the connection is censored present
or absent
the question here is to find the
communities exactly
we want to find an estimator such that
it is exactly equal to the true
community assignment with high
probability up to a global flip
and there are two cases uh that are
quite popular
people look at
the symmetric case where the age
densities
are equal in two communities and also
there is a famous problem of planted
dense subgraph problem where
you hide a smaller dense subgraph inside
a larger graph uh that case you get when
you take v2 equals q
now let me very briefly mention a few
approaches
uh the first approach one can try is to
do some maximum likelihood estimation
usually they build optimal algorithms
but
maximum likelihood estimators usually
are np hard to compute for this problem
so natural approach is to take some sdp
relaxation of the maximum likelihood
estimator well in some regime this hype
when shoe paper shows that the this sdp
algorithms can be optimal however
even though sdps are
polynomial time they are not as
efficient
and
i also should mention that these prior
works have uh conditions like the edge
densities are equal and you also have
this condition like p plus q equals one
so our interest is to see how do more
efficient algorithms such as spectral
algorithms perform uh because spectral
algorithms have much better running time
uh so we want to see how would this
algorithm perform
in the center sensor setup
so
this is the class of spectral algorithm
that
i will talk about spectral one algorithm
so you first encode the graph using some
matrix right so if there is a sensor
connection you put zero if edge is
present you put one and if there are it
is absent you put a minus one so we have
three types of information that's how we
encode it
and then we compute the top two
eigenvectors and plus then compute a
linear combination of these eigenvectors
and classify what vertices according to
whether this linear combination is more
than sub threshold or less than some
threshold
so
this is
a class of algorithm that is
well studied in the literature usually
it works
up to the information threshold if you
don't have sensor
okay so here is the first result uh
we first find the information theoretic
threshold meaning we find a dc such that
if t is less than tc you cannot come up
with any algorithm for the
exact recovery problem there are no
algorithms okay
on the other hand what happens if t is
more than tc
well
in the symmetric case and plant and
dense subgraph problem that two problem
i mentioned in the beginning
it turns out that spectral one
algorithms are optimal they work up to
the information theoretically
okay so this is a these two are cases of
success stories for spectral volume one
algorithm
and now
the question
are spectral one algorithms always
optimal
okay for two minutes okay
are spectral one algorithms always
optimal
so it turns out that uh
those were the only two cases
if you take any other case spectral
wallet on one algorithm will not be
optimal in the sense that if you are
sufficiently close to the information
theory threshold
they don't work no matter what choices
of parameters you take
okay
and
you might think is this a sign of
computational versus a statistical gap
and the answer is no and there is a good
news
we can devise an optimal spectral
algorithm ah
by instead using multiple encoding
matrices instead of a single encoding
matrix okay on the same data we can use
multiple encoding matrices to boost the
performance of spectral algorithm
okay the idea is very simple we just
take two spectral uh two encoding
matrices on the same data
right and now instead of two top
eigenvectors we have four top
eigenvectors and play the same game uh
take linear combination and classify
vertices according to if this linear
combination more than or less than one
and this class
always succeeds up to the information
theta threshold always for any parameter
and not only that there is a bonus so
this spectral two algorithm class turns
out to be not as sensitive to the choice
of encoding matrices for example as long
as this encoding parameters
are not equal and they lie outside a
finite set then spectral algorithms
always work
so this makes spectral algorithms quite
robust and
the takeaway is that spectral algorithms
can be effectively boosted by using
multiple encoding matrices on the same
data
okay
so
i would
be very happy to chat about
the interesting open questions come up
here and also
what are the intuitions for seeing these
results offline and but for now let me
thank you and end with the references
for the lovely talk questions
do you have any beliefs or results about
what happens at criticality
at dc
okay i we don't have any results but
probably my conjecture would be that
it is possible but that depends on the
situation
thanks for the great talk uh how does
this algorithm spectral algorithm
compare to the message passing algorithm
the more traditional ones for like
community detection so in this case also
we studied uh
one of these two-step algorithms uh so
in the two-step algorithms uh it turns
out that there is no gap they always
work up to the information theory
threshold so they are kind of like the
spectral two algorithms
um maybe jason you can set up well any
questions
could you explain the uh the test to
decide
uh which how to label a vertex so you
said that you said there are these two
eigenvectors so so i try to triple this
is like i look at the i
value
of the eigenvector to determine if node
i is yes i got it okay yeah
thank you
sneak in a quick question so how
important is that uh censoring
probability you said it's log n by n
okay
so in this case uh we are considering
the exact recovery uh and we initially
have a dense graph so
for the exact recovery is the final
stage final thresholding happens at this
log n over n scale so if you have uh
larger than log n over n you can always
detect
it using spectral algorithms so actually
for spectral one algorithms even it does
not work up to the information theory
threshold but if you pick a very large
enough t
after that uh the spectral one algorithm
still works it just does not work up to
the information theory
thank you
so thank you for the talk um i was
wondering how
how do you set the gammas are they
learned so the gammas once you have
fixed y1 and y2 you can compute it
explicitly okay so there are some
equations you have to solve in order to
thank you find the right commas
let me take the remaining
[Music]
so
the question is
what is the information theoretic
pressure
so
the threshold i did not write it but it
comes in terms of some turn off failing
the distance between two
distributions
okay thanks a lot
okay the next talk is